okay how do we graph piecewise functions
there's two methods I'm going to show
you in this video we roll through two
examples the first one you can see f of
X equals 2x plus 4 3 and X minus 3
squared plus 2 but it's giving us these
domain restrictions meaning we're just
going to graph that portion of the graph
so I'm going to show you a method here
where if we're graphing this is like y
equals f of X is like our Y or output
we're graphing y equals 2x plus 4 but
only when X is less than or equal to
negative 1 so what you can do if you
want is go over here to where X is
negative 1 I'm just going to draw like a
dashed or dotted line you can erase this
later if you want and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna graph the line y
equals 2x plus 4 it has a y-intercept of
4 it has a slope of 2 which means we're
going up 2 over 1 ok and you can repeat
that process okay and you can get your
line like this but we only want the part
that's less say meaning to the left of
negative 1 or equal to negative 1 so
that means that this part here at
negative 1 or to the left meaning less
than that's the part of the graph that
we want so the other part of the graph
I'm just going to go back and I'm gonna
erase because we don't actually need
that ok so now the next part y equals 3
now y equals lions remember these are
horizontal lines so I'm going to graph
the line y equals 3 but this is in
between negative 1 and 2 so if we go
over here to x equals 2 again I'm just
gonna draw like a light dashed or dotted
line we're gonna be in between negative
1 & 2 and it's the line y equals 3 so
here's y equals 3 but we only want to be
in between negative 1 & 2 so not
including negative 1 so this is going to
be open not including 2 but just less
than 2 so we're in between negative 1 &
2 notice here this was less than or
equal to negative 1 that's why I have
this as a closed circle it includes that
point this is open meaning it doesn't
include that point and the part of the
graph that we don't need now we're gonna
go back and we're gonna erase okay now
this is just one method I'm gonna show
you another method and number 2 here the
last part is y equals X minus 3 squared
plus 2 we know this is a parabola it's
in vertex form the vertex is positive 3
positive 2 so I'm going to go over here
over
you can see the a value is one it's
opening up and you can see that this
would be like if we plot some points
it's going to be like 1 1 1 1 and it's
going to look like a parabola something
like this ok but we want the part where
X is greater than meaning to the right
of or equal to 2 so this part here
that's to the left of 2 we don't
actually need I'm going to erase that
portion there and we just want the part
greater than or equal to 2 the right now
these ones having to overlap the the
open part and the closed part so that's
going to end up being like a filled in
circle and that's it now you've got your
piecewise function let's look at number
2 now I'm going to show you a different
method some students like this method
better and what you're doing is you're
graphing out these two functions now
here the dividing line is X is less than
0 meaning to the left of the y-axis or X
is greater than or equal to 0 so to the
right of the y-axis I'm not going to
draw on the lines here we can just think
of the y-axis is dividing it up into two
parts
but what I'm going to do to show you
here is I'm going to make a table and
I'm gonna pick values that are 0 or less
now 0 negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
now you might be saying well Mario this
is less than but not equal to 0 but
we're gonna still put that point in zero
in I'm just going to draw it as an open
circle on the graph because it doesn't
include 0 so let's put 0 in we get 1 if
I put negative 1 in I get negative 1
squared is 1 times a negative is
negative 1 this will give you positive 4
so that's 3 plus 1 is 4 check my math
here so this would be negative 2 squared
is 4 that's negative 4 plus 8 that's
going to be 4 plus 1 is 5 and negative 3
is going to give us a negative 9 here
plus 12 is 3 plus 1 is 4 so if we graph
these points we get 0 1 and remember how
that was less than but not equal to 0 so
this is actually going to be open okay
open not including that point negative 1
is going to be at 4 1 2 3 4 negative 2 5
which is going to be right here negative
3 4 it's going to be right here and
remember how we said we're less than but
not equal to 0 so it's just a part of
the graph going to the left of x equals
0 now for the second part y equals 3x
minus 3 we're also going to make a table
but we're gonna pick values that are 0
or
greater so I'm just gonna pick 0 1 2 3
if I put 0 in I get negative 3 if I put
1 in I get 0 if I put 2 in I get 3 if I
put 3 in I get 6 so let's go ahead and
plot these so 0 negative 3 is right here
and that's going to be closed because
it's equal to 0 so this point here is
closed 1 0 is here 2 3 is here and again
you can see we're going to the right or
greater than or equal to 0 so we want
this part of the graph not the part here
going to the left and you've got your
piecewise function this channel is all
about helping you raise your grade pass
your class and go on to pursue your
dreams making learning math less
stressful if this video helped you and
you want more help learning how to graph
a piecewise functions follow me over to
that video right there and I'll show you
some more examples